[Music]
our next animal here right on the desk
so you want to stick that over there
okay why sit oh well this is take my
face off what do I do now you can
actually just you don't want to get too
close because again this is a while down
so this is a serval right okay beautiful
medium sized cat they are native to
Africa there be there they're not as big
as sort of a lion or a leopard or a
tiger right and so people think wow what
a great idea
I'll be really awesome and really cool
and impress my friends and I'll go out
and buy one of these things these are
wild animals yeah you should never be
pets yeah but just think walking into
the club with that they're people they
have if we can get him to jump ok is
this is a species that lives in tall
grasses in Africa those really long neck
legs and long neck allow it to see over
the grass and these guys can actually
jump 10 feet in the air and catch birds
in mid-flight I've also heard with those
ears it can get DirecTV pretty much at
any right absolutely incredible
yeah the ears are you know the ears
obviously help them hone in on prey and
I don't know if you can see behind but
they've got these these light patches on
them that actually kind of look like
eyes from behind so in in in the wild
it's a cat eat cat world so if a leopard
or a lion found a serval like this kill
it and they're natural prey as a feather
on a stick yeah well it's it's a bird
let's see come on yeah he's now again
I'm playing with a cat toy they try
you've been doing a good you can give it
a try great a little more there way
there you go now we're talking you got a
just but don't put it in front of you
because you might oh I know what I'm
doing later at the hospital
look it's like me when it hears laughs
it goes
okay so but you know we're playing with
a cat toy he's on a leash again that's
not because he's a pet that's for
everybody's safety here
absolutely gorgeous right right so we
should probably move on to the next
animal that this is servile don't get it
as a pet unless you're also getting a
grizzly bear exactly exactly yeah no
even to the to even each other I've got
both one keeps the other in check yeah
yeah no leg moves out of that how
irresponsible all right so our last
animal Andy why don't you get in the
middle here oh that's this is one of my
favorite animals
this is Pugsley the Burmese python okay
Pugsley is a great example of an animal
that you actually can go out and buy as
a pet now when I tell you that why would
someone have this as a pet well for the
same reason that they would want to get
a bear or a serval they think it makes
them look cool I'm here to tell you it
not that's not true it actually makes
you kind of ignorant because if you
can't care for an animal that gets this
big and eats live or you know full-sized
chickens full size rabbits this thing
could eat a bank safe I mean I yeah he's
unbelievable he weighs 100 pounds and
he's not even full-grown this is a
species of snake that can get to be
almost 20 feet in length he's about 14
feet okay how does this creature is it
is it a can it kill a man
it could absolutely kill him and now
fortunately you know these big snakes
even in the wild are not a threat to
people but this is a species that people
got as pets then release them down on
the Florida Everglades and guess what
happened they started breeding out of
control and they're actually now now
they're voting he does this lake
[Applause]
right so I mean these guys are eating
even animals as big as alligators they
could be a threat to the endangered
Florida panther these guys could eat a
Florida panther cub so you know again
this is an animal that you can buy small
in the pet store and then it gets big if
you actually are able to keep it alive
and then what happens is that a lot of
people release them yeah into the wild
they become really bad invasive exotic
species there he goes he's back there
nope between my legs he's now up in my
yeah he's wrapping around he's crushing
me
look at me laughing at you that's right
yeah
that's actually how he would kill his
prey that's how he kills his prey or
couldst what a way to go
you